[Applaudissements]
allez les chéris le numéro est là c'est
le vrai le numéro c'est le 45 voilà
[Applaudissements]
là c'est le vrai et voilà les places
pour les places
Tony comment ça va mon chéri ça va ça va
pas bien dans le micro tu es content
d'aller voir
[Applaudissements]
elle peut venir nous rejoindre ou pas
ma chérie
[Applaudissements]
Bayern tous les deux les chéris
est-ce que vous êtes content alors
parlez bien dans le micro merci pour
tout le temps que vous êtes ensemble
tous les deux ça fait plus de 10 ans
maintenant
de fou aller voir un PSG Bayern parce
que normalement on sait où on est avec
sa meuf on voit PG Bayern
qui va être dans le même lit que Messi
Neymar
c'est incroyable non mais franchement
c'est beau ou pas surtout qu'à Matane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chérie que je rajoute une surprise car
c'est la Saint-Valentin ce soir j'ai une
petite surprise et mon ami Hervé Mathoux
que j'aime qui va bien sûr être ce soir
sur Canal+ à une petite surprise pour
vous il y avait gagné le numéro 45
regarde
salut Jennifer salut Tony Cyril vient de
m'informer que c'était vous les grands
vainqueurs vous avez gagné deux places
pour le Parc des Princes ce soir bravo
vous auriez pu regarder le match sur
Canal à 21h ce soir mais ça va on fera
sans vous régalez-vous vous êtes
chanceux ça va être super
juste les gars et là tous les
téléspectateurs se disent on est sur C8
comment Hanouna a fait aussi vite
pour prévenir est vraiment Jennifer et
Tony les deux gagnants c'est fort et
bien parce que les chéris c'est
complètement que ça allait tonique elle
a gagné
aujourd'hui c'était là aujourd'hui
j'ai monté tout ça avec la prod d'accord
mon amour voilà plus de 10 ans que nous
sommes ensemble nous avons tous en
montagne les bons comme les mauvais
moments tu m'as apporté tout ce que je
souhaitais dans ma vie des beaux enfants
à domicile et tout sur le plan
professionnel tu as su stabiliser ma vie
personnelle et professionnelle et pour
ça je t'en remercie du fond du cœur je
t'aime
la boucle est bouclée il ne manque plus
qu'une chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh merci ma chérie
pas mal
[Applaudissements]
ah ma chérie
ça va ma chérie alors
attendez attendez attendez j'ai pas eu
ma réponse j'ai pas eu ma réponse pour
l'instant pour l'instant tu vas juste
on a pas eu la réponse
attendez monsieur on a un micro tout de
suite toi
jeudi oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toute la famille était là
bravo les chéris merci merci
et je voulais juste dire une chose si je
n'ai pas fait avant c'est parce qu'elle
m'a toujours demandé quelque chose de
grand et je sais que Cyril voilà tous
les soirs on le regarde avec nos enfants
et deux enfants ils l'adorent mais nous
on l'adore
et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui voilà je
voulais que Cyril soit présent avec nous
auprès de Nous chaque soir on le regarde
et c'était le moment parfait pour te
demander je voulais remercier également
Mokhtar qui est là Adèle et toute la
production merci beaucoup Adèle et merci
à toute la production Cyril reste comme
tu es et vous avez comme témoin Jean
Rachid et bouder
c'est pas mal
la bague est là je vais remercier
je vais vous dire mes chéries je suis
très très heureux pour vous vous êtes
une femme venez chez parce que c'est
toute la famille qui est là les trois
enfants là c'est les parents j'ose dire
je suis très heureux pour vous les
chéris je souhaite beaucoup beaucoup de
bonheur et voilà tant qu'on pourra vous
aider on sera là et vous venez vous nous
voir quand vous voulez là ce soir soirée
de fou parce que vous allez voir PSG
Bayern après nuit de noces
et après bien entendu mariage j'espère
qu'on sera invité j'espère qu'on sera
invité au mariage j'espère avec plaisir
merci
[Applaudissements]
une dernière personne qui a vraiment qui
compte vraiment vraiment beaucoup pour
nous vraiment les chéris et qui on
n'aura pas pu faire ce enfin ce beau
moment sans elle je remercie Fatou
d'avoir rendu la bague
c'est pas trop
[Applaudissements]